it's violent riddled with ethnic hatred
dangerous tensions bullying nationalists
bravado but it's not just Vladimir Putin
and the Russians who have a passion for
the Crimean Peninsula the Crimea is a
sparkling jewel set enticingly in the
Black Sea it's been coveted by many
peoples and nations over 2,000 years of
history the Huns the Goths and the
Mongols as well as the Greeks and the
Turks were just some of the settlers and
invaders who wanted to possess it but
the Russian Empire led by Catherine the
Great annexed the Crimea in 1783 as part
of her ambition to push south starting a
love affair with the peninsula which
prevails today the current efforts of
Britain and other European allies to
contain Russian ambitions in the Crimea
have echoes in history but with a much
bloodier outcome cannon to right of them
cannon to left of them cannon in front
of them volleyed and thundered stormed
that with shot and shell boldly they
rode and well into the jaws of death
into the mouth of hell rode the 600 the
charge of the Light Brigade
one of the most dramatic moments in the
Crimean War when Britain and her allies
attempted to stop Russian expansionism
using the Crimean Peninsula as a
bridgehead it gave us terms like The
Thin Red Line and the first Victoria
Cross this permanent exhibition at the
National Army Museum on the Crimean
campaign shows how it was the birthplace
of modern nursing
there's even an example of one of
florence Nightingale's lamps no matter
how indelibly printed the crimea
campaign is on british history that is
insignificant in comparison to what it
means to the russians the Crimean
Peninsula is indelibly burnt on to the
Russian psyche it is the jewel in their
crown and it remains so until it was
snatched by Germany in World War two the
German assault sparked some of the
bloodiest fighting on the east and front
in the summer of 1942
until a massive offensive regained the
Crimea for Moscow two years later they
are preparing to evacuate to the Crimea
taking Soviet civilians with them for
slave labor the Crimea then played its
part in the future of the world when
Churchill Roosevelt and Stalin met at
Yalta in 1945 to carve the shape of the
post-war global landscape between them
Stalin quickly moved to change the
ethnic balance of the peninsula in favor
of Russians he deported two hundred
thousand ethnic Tatars who he accused of
collaborating with the Nazis soon though
the Crimea became a resort area for the
Soviet elite Gorbachev had a holiday
dacha here more than a million Russians
still take their annual vacation on the
peninsula this place is less pleased
I would awaken the root of today's
conflict lies in a whimsical decision
taken by Soviet leader Nikita Khrushchev
in 1954 most of the people in Crimea
have never been happy with the fact that
Chris Jeff sixty years ago without
consulting them detached their region
from the Russian Republic and gave it to
Ukraine it didn't matter very much in
Soviet times but it certainly mattered
after the so tuna collapsed in 1991
tension over the Crimea increased
quickly through the 90s when Kiev and
Moscow squabbled over the future of
Russia's Black Sea Fleet at Sebastopol
and it's still seen by Putin as a
Russian strategic necessity in law the
Crimea is Ukrainian but in the hearts of
many perhaps most Russians it was only
ever on loan to their neighbor now
Crimea is just days away from a
referendum on secession never shy of
showing his enthusiasm for the region
Vladimir Putin unexpectedly turned up
here at a Russian nationalist biker
convention and now just as unexpectedly
Russian troops have stolen back the
Crimean jewel Sam Kiley sky news